they start before dawn
fishermen in the city of bayern need to
be out on the water all day to make it
worth their while
let's go
joao davrillo learned his trade from his
father
he grew up in the fishing community of
praia nova
today he heads up the local fishing
cooperative and knows just where to get
the best catch
bring it in bring it in
but times are hard there are fewer fish
now
often their nets come up empty the sea
itself though is their biggest worry
every year storm tides inundate their
homes
they destroy our boats our houses entire
villages
the last one covered our houses in 10
meters of water
for the port city of bayer and its
fishing industry the sea is a vital
source of income
but every november when the cyclone
season starts it becomes dangerous
so the city is investing in green
infrastructure designed to absorb the
destructive force of the flood waters
over the last five years bera has begun
to restore the natural watercourses and
basins
mangroves have been planted along the
banks flanked by large parks
the big green park at the center
covering 44 hectares of land
is now almost complete city mayor albano
has come to inspect the world
the gardeners need to trim this area
again it's dried out a bit
these green areas are designed to absorb
the flood waters like a sponge
holding back the worst from the city
has become a pioneer in green
infrastructure on the african continent
we need to think about how we can
continue living in this city
how we can cope with the challenge of
climate change without creating even
more problems for the city
we need to act decisively and
sustainably and develop a sustainable
lifestyle for our city
much more difficult i mean a better
place so that piero will be safer and
more prosperous
and more attractive to businesses
but it means the fishing community has
to move
pryonova is located in a former mangrove
swamp
which will now be replanted residents
are being asked to move to camps on the
edge of the city
like this one in mandruzi far away from
the sea
former fisherman leandro mungua lost his
home and his boat to cyclone edie in
2019
so he moved here voluntarily he now
lives from farming
and is building his own house
[Music]
i would never go back no one wants to
return to that way of life
because it's difficult and dangerous
it's like fighting a war not against
armed men
but against water and water is not an
easy opponent
our future is here but not if we fold
our arms
we have to work hard
the city authorities offered him and 200
other fishermen
small plots of land each on which to
farm and build a home
it's an area that's safe from flooding
and suitable for growing rice
but not everyone shares mongoas optimism
the house of his neighbor bernardo
matello was flattened by powerful winds
matelo would rather sell fish like he
used to but that's not an option here
we can't afford to travel to the sea and
buy fish to sell it here
no one could make a living that way so
we're growing rice instead
but the soil is depleted this year we
had a lot of rice
but because the rains failed everything
is withered
during a visit to a residential area on
the coast mayor carrich appeals for
support for his plans
wave breakers are to be built in the sea
here
protecting the city from future floods
is his top priority
and he takes every opportunity to
persuade local people of the need for
change
he believes projects like the green park
and the relocation of prior nova
are vital for the city's future and he's
hoping local residents will support him
we need to use all our knowledge and
expertise to pull the city out of the
swamps
that's why we're organizing big projects
and paying out money
because we want to govern better and
serve the people better
all with the goal of ensuring that
tomorrow we're no longer on the list of
cities
most threatened by climate change
as grandest grand
on the other side of the bay the
fishermen continue working at praia nova
at the moment relocation to the camps is
voluntary
many realize that it's too dangerous to
stay here long term
but joao de vrio and his colleagues find
it hard to believe they would make good
farmers
i don't think moving to the camps is the
answer whether in dama or rio maria
why not protect the coast from erosion
and we stay here and continue to fish
for a living
as the fishing cooperative of prayanova
finding a safe place to live that is
both close enough to the water
and affordable is certainly not
realistic otherwise
you